Marine Le Pen voilet Emmanuel Macron est
bornier ou Valérie Pécresse LGBT vous
avez peut-être aperçu cette affiche près
de chez vous c'est l'idée de cet artiste
de rue jairai me qui détourne les
portraits des candidats à la
présidentielle idée de ce projet appelé
distorsion peindre des personnalités
politiques qui stigmatisent des groupes
à partir de réels phrases qu'ils ont dit
dans la réalité moins du coup ça m'a
touché et donc du coup j'ai décidé de
faire comme une sorte de réponse une
réponse artistique donc avec des
peintures c'est initiative est saluée
par certains d'autres dénoncent le fait
que ces affiches soient collées soient
des panneaux officiels sans être
sanctionnés ces répréhensible par la loi
450 euros d'amende alors condamnez-vous
de ces affiches parodiques
[Musique]
alors moi personnellement je trouve ça
formidable j'adore je trouve ça top mais
enfin et puis c'est bien fait c'est bon
je comprends la démarche artistique elle
est très belle mais pas sur ces panneaux
électoraux pas aujourd'hui pas au moment
des élections c'est désacraliser la
fonction résidentielle puisque un de ces
candidats on sait pas lequel sera
président vous sera président ce n'est
pas respectueux il ne fallait pas le
faire aujourd'hui donc je suis
totalement contre moi je trouve ça
génial qui a une vraie tension sociale
il y a de plus en plus de gens qui s'en
prennent physiquement qui insultent les
candidats là c'est de manière artistique
de répondre sans violence et c'est très
bien de le faire voilà il faut il faut
condamner la violence et ça c'est une
manière très intelligente de répondre
voilà alors vous
[Applaudissements]
en revanche surtout c'est assez étonnant
que sur Pécresse il est le truc gay
sous-entendu un peu bah tu vois la
couleur
ne serait-ce pas tellement les
République non mais c'est les
républicains ils étaient ouais c'est
bizarre c'est tout ouais
non moi j'adore je trouve que l'art de
toute façon c'est politique c'est
militant c'est comme des caricatures
donc moi je trouve ça très fort après
timon on voit qu'il est on voit qu'il
est d'un côté c'est à dire qu'il y a pas
une caricature de Mélenchon il y a il a
fait Hollande avec les 100 dents très
réussi
qui est très réussi en mode voilà
regardez
c'est François Hollande on appelle le
dîner chez Géraldine maillet
et en fait là où c'est très fort dans ce
qu'il fait c'est que sur son instinct il
y a 11 11000 déjà Jean-Luc Mélenchon
politique et pourquoi pas après tout je
trouve que moi l'art il avait mangé hein
c'est qu'en fait il va on voit
particulièrement pendant Pécresse il a
fait au Marais dans le Marais pardon il
va faire Zemmour il l'a fait à Montreuil
Hollande il a fait à Tulle Sarko à La
Courneuve et Marine Le Pen a Sangatte et
à Calais justement pour les questions de
migrants mais voilà mais après j'aurais
voulu qu'il détourne le truc et qu'il
aille faire un truc avec Mélenchon voilà
pour montrer aussi des des livres qu'il
a pu avoir
la politique c'est trop sérieux mais non
en ce moment la matière est là bas mais
oui mais ça c'est facile
[Applaudissements]
électoraux à quelques jours d'une
élection fondamentale
d'abord d'abord Cyril le disait en
préambule d'abord c'est un délit vous
n'avez pas le droit et en plus c'est une
manière de dire que c'est politique qui
sont si décrié bah finalement on peut se
moquer d'eux on peut les structurer
c'est le candidat bashing et moi je
reprends des phrases des candidats et en
fonction d'une phrase particulière il a
compris madame qui dit oui mais moi je
dis oui je suis un peu moins radical que
Gilles mais je j'aime bien l'objet
artistique il est fait ça fait rire
c'est donc pas sur les panneaux
électrons je suis désolé c'est pour
alors c'est un délit mais c'est même un
scandale je suis désolé oui excusez-moi
il y a une fonction il y a quelque chose
et mais c'est normal Géraldine que c'est
un acte politique et ça je j'aimerais
que ce soit dans un magasin
justement tous à tout ce qui déteste
dedans mais pourquoi elles ont Mélenchon
exactement
j'aurais aimé voir Mélenchon aussi voilà
mais autrement dit
quel message il veut faire passer et ça
c'est respectable après
avoir en camion tu vois en travaux
aussi c'est de les voir réagir à ces
images de voir comment eux candidats
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais comment tu veux que les émissions
c'est juste de là il y a rien
d'insultant parce que porter le voile
c'est pas insultant changer de religion
c'est pas insultant être gilet jaune
c'est pas insultant c'est tout
simplement des gens qui ont des valeurs
totalement aux antipodes et qui se
rejoignent le temps quoi aussi c'est une
phrase toute seule